hallo hallo christoph meine frage an
dich wäre wenn er nix studioalbum
erscheint oder ob die cessna neue
studioalbum von den beginnern erscheint
das würde mich natürlich auch freuen und
wenn du jetzt beantworten würde ich das
dein neues album in zwei oder drei
jahren erscheint dass ich mich
interessieren die musikrichtung er wäre
so bank oder reggae amy dann es ist
einfach ich freue mich auf den antwort
und dankeschön also ich würde jetzt auch
mal interessieren ob es vielleicht
irgendwie eine pille gibt gegen armut
und dann würde mich noch interessieren
nein also dass inhalt fragen wie kann
ich so nicht beantworten
weil
sowas kommt so was kann man nicht das
ist halt bei kreativen dingen so
man kann sich da nicht drauf verlassen
allerdings kann ich mich konnte ich mich
jedenfalls rückblicken darauf verlassen
dass irgendwann dann immer so was kam
einfach so rein genauso wie dieses
zucken wenn man wieder auf tour gehen
will oder ein studio und ich kann nur
sagen dass ich mir jetzt bei den ganzen
rastlosigkeit unterwegs seien einfach
nichts mehr wünscht als ende dieses
jahres für ein jahr wirklich komplett
alles abzusagen und mich ein jahr im
studio einzuschließen und einfach nur
musik zu machen und zwar für nichts also
weder für den neue jahren die lebt hatte
noch für irgendwas mit mich mit dennis
und mad also mit den beginnern treffen
mit den songs machen mich mit meiner
disco number one band treffen und und
fang songs machen aber auch punk rock
mal auszuprobieren und mal elektro songs
selber zu machen und einfach nur musik
zu machen ohne ziel das ist mein ziel
und das will ich ein jahr lang machen
und ich glaube dass ich in dem ja auch
schön runter komme und dann mal
entspannt wieder hamburg genießen kann
und dann auch anhand der musik geht dann
mache weiß merken werde das gefällt mir
das nicht das gefällt mir das nicht und
dann wird sich herauskristallisieren was
die nächste platte wird wenn die sachen
mit matt und dann ist einfach der
oberschicht sind dann werden wir sofort
nach beginn habt hatte geben wenn ich
aber auf einmal an heavy metal tango
feuer gefangen habe dann wird es eine
heavy metal tango platte vielleicht
sogar mit scooter werden keine ahnung
also ich will einfach erstmal nur musik
machen alles was ich will